a little Marie and you introduce Pete  unhooked on Phonics yeah a little bit a  little crazy so what and I think you're  a little crazy to the way you're  thinking is that my mark up there yeah  what's a special house yeah it's all  edible what do you recommend I don't  know it's all desert this is it man  little energy you can yell out a little  bit  ready action cut you can yell out a  little bit all right all right  goody box getting stronger  dynamite explosion  we go  fight to survive headbutt some head  busing is a fight to survive hair bus a  bus  the  it's a fight to survive hey what's up  and bust the only king of the ring ring  ring the bell then upcoming now swing  swing swing it laughs winging right to  the game ding he hit the ground